what else is grease really getting out
of this well they get a little loosening
on their primary fiscal surplus it's
three percent this year that's the
surplus they have to run and it's four
and a half next year the wording in the
language is to take account of Greece's
current economic situation so they'll be
able to loosen that that's the big thing
they got what they need to do though is
a buy by the agreements and on Monday
night the agreements of the previous
bailout package and on Monday night they
need to submit an action plan that
action plan will then be reviewed by the
EU and then on Tuesday morning there
will be a conference call there's still
a chance Trish and I stress still and
chance that this could blow up and that
is if what Greece submits Monday night
doesn't pass muster you just heard
Christine Lagarde hint at that this is
very much going to be done in stages and
tranches and crucially Greece doesn't
get money they don't get their next
batch of money until April now there's
still a lot more on this agreement that
we need to figure out who really one who
really dug and where we'll be doing that
in the next couple of hours for now
though we have an agreement and it looks
like markets like this four-month
extension well I guess we can anticipate
a lot of politicking over the weekend in
Athens